[Music]
in the Grandeur of Saint Peter's
Basilica the traditional New Year's Day
Mass was delivered by Pope Francis to a
packed congregation
but this year's service at the Vatican
was to be particularly poignant
following the death on Saturday of the
man he'd succeeded Pope Emeritus
Benedict XVI
foreign
the key to Hope is Mary
the antiphon of Hope is the invocation
of the holy mother of God
and we ask through her intercession that
she accompanies Pope Benedict on his way
Pope Benedict stood down as the head of
the Roman Catholic Church in 2013 eight
years after being elected
a rare occurrence he was the first to
resign the papacy since the 15th century
citing his old age and declining health
[Music]
it means a rare opportunity for a
serving Pope to preside over the funeral
of a predecessor due to be held on
Thursday morning
but first from Monday thousands are
expected to visit the same huge Basilica
for the 95 year old will lie in state
for three days
as Pope he was criticized for not doing
enough to address sexual abuse
allegations within the church
but here there were only tributes
despite the fact he was always very
reserved he leaves a very important mark
on the church on the world on people
we know
Benedict Was a greater Theologian was a
man of culture of reflection
he had an incredible charism
after the morning service Pope Francis
emerged struggling with crippling knee
pain to cheers and Applause from The
Waiting crowd in Saint Peter's Square
during his address he took the
opportunity to remember those living
through war in Ukraine
celebrating the world day of peace today
let us regain awareness of the
responsibility that's been entrusted to
us to construct the future in the face
of the personal and social crisis we are
living in and the tragedy of the war
it will be in this square that
Thursday's service will be conducted
simple by comparison with previous papal
funerals in keeping with Pope Benedict's
wishes
with official delegations attending only
from Italy and his native Germany
his papacy was not without controversy
but he will be remembered as one of the
great theologians of his time
Emma birchley Sky News